it's time for et social study a quick
update of what the Stars are posting
online Selena Gomez lobs off her locs
hairstylist marissa moreno shared the
photo of Selena's new due to Instagram
Cindy Crawford is fresh-faced
and flawless while taking in the
sunlight Jill Dillard of the Duggar
family poses with her growing baby bump
and days after the birth of her son gray
Douglas stuper Molly Sims is sharing
sweet family photos of her tribe of five
brother and sister pitching in to help I
think I killed her
sarah michelle gellar caught dead
working out with Shannon Daugherty she
captioned the post the Slayer and the
cancer Slayer Sarah Michelle Gellar
being supportive through thick and thin
but Sarah had a scary incident the night
before when she had to take one of her
children to the ER for the very first
time she and Freddie Prinze jr. 'he's
four year old son Araki was admitted for
an apparent nasty virus sarah wrote of
the incident watching your child not be
able to breathe is the most helpless I
have ever felt
you